celebrities in general are not the
wisest people often have a myopic view
of the world often think that everything
revolves around them and that nothing
came before them uh this video is going
viral yesterday this is this is
absolutely incredible so Jennifer
Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence was in Hunger
Games she was uh she was in X-Men who's
the blue girl Mystique she was Mystique
in the the new X-Men movies she's done a
couple other things uh here she is
saying that before her there were no
chicks doing lead acting roles in action
movies I think she may have a limited
memory I remember when I was doing
Hunger Games nobody had ever put a woman
in the lead of an action movie because
it wouldn't work we were told girls and
boys can both identify with a male lead
but boys cannot identify with a female
lead oh absolutely and it just makes me
so happy every single time I see a movie
come out that just blows through every
single one of those beliefs and proves
that it is just a lie to keep certain
people out of the movies to keep certain
people in the same positions that
they've always been in and it's just
amazing to watch it happen and watch you
at the helm guys there's been a massive
conspiracy that Jennifer Lawrence has
unfurled she did it Scooby-Doo style she
ripped the mask off before her there
were no lead actors in action movies
it's not as if the internet exists where
you might be able to video
I can handle myself
yeah I noticed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
congrats Jennifer Lawrence you just
erased all of those chicks unless she
knows something we don't know maybe she
knows they all have penises in which
case they're still chicks right isn't
that how this thing works it's also
confusing anyway just such silliness
like this it's the same sort of
um like very narrow view of the world
Meghan Markle comes into the monarchy
and thinks that she knows best about
everything and should disassemble it
Jennifer Lawrence comes into Hollywood
and thinks no one did anything before
her it's this weird thing it's this
weird thing about that has something to
do with people I don't know maybe under
the age of 40 like everything before
them was so horrible and backwards it's
such nonsense nonsense